I'm Ben Higgins and I'm gonna read the
most dramatic tweets ever about me Ben
Higgins is the most genuine human being
and I honestly want him to find love
more than a lot of people I know
personally that's so sweet
I wish that the bachelor could bottle
Ben Higgins pure understated charisma I
should find him incredibly boring but
instead I am grit this makes me feel so
special it really does
we are not worthy but Ben Higgins not
worthy
you're so worthy Ben Higgins deserves
the world and all the happiness and
anything less is a crime these are I
like people a lot right now
Dean Ben Higgins cry makes me want to
die is it that bad only is that bad this
guy the airport looks like Ben Higgins
and I want to die there's a lot of death
involved in my name right now again when
I die I want Ben Higgins to lure me into
my grave so that he can let me down one
more time is it it's not a compliment is
it no I don't think so I'm sorry I fell
letting you down it wasn't my intention
Ben Higgins is the love of my life I
hope so
I've been looking for that person so so
if you're out there and you mean this I
appreciate you
[Music]
[Applause]